men rule the world they're in charge of everything
I think we just need a little place to get
do you think that spaces that are designed specifically for women
are discriminatory
that's exactly what a Tasmanian court is currently debating
I'm Doctor Zoe and I start my PhD at the school of design
specifically looking at gender and place
so I obviously wanna talk about it
now if you're not familiar with Australia
there's that little triangle at the bottom
which is called Tasmania Tasmania has a pretty famous art gallery called Mona
and in that art gallery is something called the Ladies Lounge
it is a lounge where you get served champagne
and you get to relax on velvet couches
and it's only for people who identify as women
so one man went to Mona
and he soon discovered that he would not be allowed access into the ladies lab
so what did he decide to do
he decided to take the artist to court for discrimination
because he feels it's unfair that he doesn't get to experience the artwork
and he also thinks that men should be able to experience it
or that women should have to pay more for access to the entire art gallery
because they get access to more spaces than men do in the art gallery
but that's not actually true
men do get to experience the artwork just as much as women do
not in the same way but just as much
as women do
men get to experience what it feels like to feel excluded from certain spaces
men get to experience what it feels like to pay the same but get less
men get to experience what it feels like to be jealous
of the level of comfort that another gender get to experience
men get all of those things as a part of the artwork
and if men were allowed in the ladies lounge
then it wouldn't be the artwork
so
why should women have to pay more for something that men also get to experience
just because men might not like it as much as women
is art there to be liked enjoyed
or is art there to make us ponder
think question I hope that these are the things that the judge considers
but the thing that really gets me about this case
is that it's men who invented gender segregation in the first place
there is a seat in the city of Melbourne that is for ladies only
that was designed by men
there are still clubs that only get to be experienced by men
even Rotary International
uh I think until recently all men might still have some male only
but of course
we know that women are still excluded from many leadership positions
but this was formalised until relatively recently
women were not allowed in certain spaces of leadership or government
women weren't allowed in pubs
women weren't allowed bank accounts
and even though we're now allowed in these spaces
have you ever walked into a pub and just felt completely like it's not for you
like you feel unsafe you feel overly perceived
you don't feel comfortable because there's this underlying um
energy that it's not for you
I really hope that the court finds
that the Ladies Lounge can continue to operate
because
I think that it will set a really interesting precedent in the court system
one that doesn't already exist
which is why this is such an interesting case
it will set a really interesting precedent for the way that space and gender
and discrimination intersect
and I believe it will set a precedent that
basically says that these types of spaces can exist under certain circumstances
IE for equity reasons rather than for discriminatory reasons
either way I think it's really excellent
that the artist is choosing to use this moment as an extension of the artwork
itself it's basically performance art
every interview she is giving
every um
court appearance she has
she's using it as an extension of the artwork to make the point
prove that point continue that point
double down and I love it so much